ALEX DANILO: Hi, everybody.
My name is Alex Danilo.
I'm in developer relations and
on Chrome, and I have today
with me Alexis Deveria
from Adobe.
Alexis, of course, is the
man who built the site
caniuse.com, which is a
fantastic resource for anybody
doing HTML5 development.
We're going to show you a whole
lot of stuff today.
We're talking about CSS filters,
but most of all,
we're talking about a new next
generation reading experience.
So this is built with not just
CSS filters, but a whole lot
of web technologies, so we're
going to cover stuff that uses
WebGL, uses SVG, uses Canvas,
uses a whole lot of stuff, all
working together to bring you
a seamless experience.
And of course, this is
all about trees, OK?
So when we talk about
DOM trees in the
browser, we get excited.
Or at least I do.
I don't know about you guys.
But of course, today, we're
talking about the world's
biggest tree in mass, and it's
called The President.
And National Geographic has this
beautiful, beautiful site
that they've built with Adobe's
help, and we're going
to talk all about that today.
So what are CSS filters,
I'm sure you're asking?
Well, you build these beautiful
DOM tree things
inside your browser, and then
the browser comes along and it
goes, well, we need
to see that thing.
So the browser lays it out,
places all the elements on the
page, and then it gets
styled, and CSS comes
along and styles it.
And then we have this
post-processing step, which is
a CSS filter.
So if you can imagine baking
a cake, you get all your
ingredients, you put them
together, you bake it.
That's your web page.
You want to make it look good,
so you put a bit of
icing on the top.
And then you sprinkle sugar, and
CSS filters are the sugar,
which makes it look
even better.
And so once you've done the
filter, you then push it to
the screen.
So once you've generated a
bitmap, the bitmap can be
filtered inside the browser, and
then that eventually ends
up on the page.
And that's what you look at.
So where did this all begin?
This all began with
SVG, of course.
Now SVG's a graphics language,
which you all know from HTML5.
And within SVG, there are
basic filter primitives.
But these filter primitives are
like building blocks, so
you kind of combine them all
together to end up with the
effect that you want.
So if you have a look at this
graphic at the top, we have a
standard graphic on the left.
And then we generate
a blur from that.
So you take the blur, and then
the second filter offsets that
blur a little bit.
The third filter puts lighting
on the blur, which then gives
you this kind of 3D effect.
The next filter along the chain
clips the blurred lit
piece to the original graphic
so that it only hits the
original graphic.
The next stage of that pipeline
combines the original
graphic with the filtered piece
we just created, which
gives you this nice little 3D
with the second last image.
And then following that, we add
the drop shadow from the
second stage again, and
we get this nice
drop shadow 3D effect.
And this is a whole lot of
individual steps which you
have to write in SVG.
So this bottom right image, of
course, is actual text, which
is filtered using this
style of technique.
So the beauty of doing something
like this is you get
these incredible graphics, but
they're accessible, and
they're real text.
So you can select them, you
can do all sorts of stuff.
So the thing about trying to do
something like this in SVG
is you need quite
a lot of markup.
So along came CSS filters, and
CSS filters are basically a
beautiful little shorthand that
saves you a lot of pain
and a lot of markup.
And this is how easy
it is to use.
So here we just have
a class selector.
We're saying filter,
blur, 4 pixels.
And so this takes the image
on the left and
blurs it by 4 pixels.
So that's all the markup you
have to do, whereas in SVG,
that would have been a
whole ton of markup.
Now, what's nice about
these primitives is
you can combine them.
You can actually put multiple
filters on your content.
So, for example, you just
have to do something
as simple as this.
You just line them up
one after the other.
So here we have a hue-rotate
followed by sepia.
So we've taken a picture from
IO last year, and we've just
applied two filters in order.
Now, the thing to keep in mind
is that you can apply as many
filters you like, and they'll be
applied from left to right,
one after the other, which
is great, because
order actually matters.
So in this case, we've
shifted the hue and
we've sepia toned it.
But if we were to flip these
around the other way, we'd
have something like that.
So as you can see, the color
is actually different.
They're exactly the
same filters, just
in a different order.
See?
Sepia and blueish tinge.
So the beauty of these CSS
shorthands are that, because
people implementing browsers
spend all day hacking code,
because that's what we love to
do, because there's a finite
number of these shorthands, we
can actually optimize those
inside the browser.
So right now in Chrome, most
of these are hardware
accelerated.
So if you do a blur or
something, you don't get the
penalty you would've
got 12 months ago.
So there's only like 12
shorthands, and here is, of
course, the definitive prefix
version with the normal markup
of every single filter being
applied to something.
Right.
So, enough of my yakking.
Let's just show you what
we've built first.
We're going to start with the
desktop experience, because
that, of course, is something
a bit special.
And then we're going to show
you this all running on
mobile, which hasn't been shown
before, by the way.
So anyway, I'll pass it over
to Alexis, who will run you
through the desktop
experience.
ALEXIS DEVERIA: Thank
you, Alex.
So this is the project that
Adobe developed using content
from National Geographic.
It's a really beautiful article
about the great
sequoia trees.
As I scroll down here, I'm
going to go through the
different technologies that we
developed to create this next
generation reading experience.
So as I start here, the first
thing you see here
is this drop cap.
So what we use here to make this
text follow the contour
of the letter O is something
called CSS shapes or CSS
exclusions.
And let me show you a little
bit about how that works by
inspecting that.
So we set here the
webkit-shape-outside property
with an ellipse, and that's
what creates the shape.
So this is a floated element,
and the inline text just kind
of flows nicely around it,
which creates a great
typographical look.
As I scroll down, you see this
image comes into view.
And whenever these images come
into view, and also this one I
hover over, you can see how we
change both the saturation and
also the sepia.
So let me also take
a look at that.
So just as Alex mentioned,
this is
one of the CSS filters.
So by default, this has a sepia
and a grayscale of 0.5.
When we hover over that,
we change that to none.
So this is a video that's about
the photoshoot that was
done for this.
As you can see, it went to
fullscreen HTML5 video.
As I scroll down here, we see
this pull quote, and the pull
quote uses something called
text balancing.
Now, text balancing is still
a proposal, so this was
implemented using a JavaScript
polyfill.
And what it does is it ensures
that each line is roughly the
same width.
So instead of specifying where
you want your breaks, using
text balancing, it will
automatically be formatted.
So if I resize the window
enough, you'll see that now
the text becomes three lines.
Let me drag that here.
So instead of where the browser
would normally move
things over word by word using
text balancing, yours get this
great formatted text regardless
of the width.
Again, here, this image
comes into view.
We change the opacity filter.
I can click on it, put
it in full screen.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about CSS regions.
So this is a technology that we
use here on the body text.
And what CSS regions do is
they let you define your
content in one area in the DOM,
but define the elements
that the content flows
through elsewhere.
So the author has complete
control over where the text
will display without having to
modify the markup itself.
So you can see that in action
here, where we've got these
two columns.
And if I select this text, you
can see it pretty good.
I resize the window.
As you can see, the text flows
from one to the next.
So throughout this article, we
define all the different
regions and different places to
position the text the way
we want it to.
Again, let's scroll this
image into view.
As you see, it went from black
and white to color.
Here we use another CSS shape.
As you can see, the text
here roughly follows
the background image.
That just creates a very nice
look in combination with the
photograph.
So I can look at this
one real quick.
This was done using
webkit-shape-inside and a polygon.
So that defined the CSS shape
that the text flows into.
And now to scroll down
here, we get to--
so here you see a thumbnail of
the tree that Alex mentioned,
The President.
And what we wanted to do is
create a visualization where
you could actually see or kind
of get an idea of just how
immense this tree is.
And to talk a bit about the
technology behind that, I'm
going to hand things
back over to Alex.
ALEX DANILO: Thanks, Alexis.
OK.
Right.
I just want to talk a little
bit about triangles now.
Down at the bottom here, you see
a Delaunay triangulation.
So normal filters are things
that operate on pixels.
So the basic filters we showed
at the start-- things like
saturation and the color,
the monochrome--
those are pixel operations.
When you get into the world of
WebGL and shaders, you have
two types of shaders.
You have per pixel things, which
are also called fragment
shaders, but you also
have vertex shaders.
And what they do is basically
take an object or polygon,
chop it up into triangles, and
then you can write the shader
program which manipulates
these triangle points.
The beauty of that is it all
runs on the GPU, and so in
this case, we're going to
introduce WebGL and a proposal
called CSS custom filters.
So a lot of people are already
familiar with WebGL, and we're
going to show you WebGL in a
moment with one of these
experiences.
But also, CSS custom filters
are slightly different.
The difference with CSS custom
filters are basically that CSS
custom filters operate on any
arbitrary web page content.
So you can take a normal web
page and effectively flatten
it to a plane, and then
manipulate it
using a shader program.
Now, why would you want to do
this rather than use WebGL is
a question people
have asked me.
Because it's really easy.
Because WebGL actually takes
quite a lot of JavaScript to
set up, and also WebGL has no
access to the DOM or any of
the content on the page.
The thing about using something
like a CSS custom
filter is that you can take
advantage of the really good
typography that's inside
the browser.
So most browsers these days
rasterize with subpixel
anti-aliasing, and that doesn't
happen in WebGL or
Canvas, for that matter.
So by using a custom filter,
you can actually take
advantage of that.
So if you can imagine this page
here with text and a bit
of SVG graphic, what you would
do is you would basically draw
a triangle mesh over the top
of it, and then you would
write a write a shader program
which would manipulate your
web content.
And if you took this and did
that, you'd end up with
something that looks a
little bit like this.
So here is a CSS shader.
This is actually rendered
by the browser and being
manipulated, and so it's the
content that's moving around.
So you can do things like page
flips or deformations or
things like that, which is kind
of a really nice effect.
So in any case, why don't we
actually have a look at this?
I would like you to pay
close attention.
So here we have The President,
and we wanted to have the
experience where we actually
brought forward the sheer size
of this tree.
And when they built this thing,
it was like, how do you
actually represent an image?
Like, the thumbnail here, you
don't actually get a feel for
how big it is.
So pay close attention.
Look at the start.
I want you to observe
something, and watch
the tree fly in.
So what's happening here is
there is a gigantic image of
the tree that's been sliced
up into tiles, and
they're all flying in.
This is all WebGL.
And as it comes in, you see at
the bottom that there's a
person right there.
And there it is.
So it kind of gives you
a feel of how big
this actual tree is.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX DANILO: And as you can
see, of course, there are
people up here in this
tree somewhere.
And it pans around
beautifully.
Look at that.
It's basically nice and smooth,
and this is all WebGL
accelerated.
Now, the astute people in the
audience may have noticed,
right at the start of that tree
flying in, there was a
little graphic that appeared
for a fraction of a second.
And what was happening there is
that we were trying to get
the texture from CPU memory
over into GPU memory.
So the way this has been built
is by constructing a giant
texture, slicing it up into
rectangles, and then
referencing them from
the WebGL context.
But of course, this is one huge
texture, and that takes
time to get across
into GPU RAM.
So that little spinning thing
that you saw just before the
tree appeared was actually
referencing the WebGL texture
in a 1 by 1 pixel kind
of reference.
So that 1 by 1 pixel reference
was enough to pull the whole
texture across so that when
the tree flew in, it was
actually nice and fluid.
It's kind of a nice,
neat little trick.
Now the other thing is also here
that this is very similar
to DOM spriting.
So people who have done DOM
spriting, you typically load
one big image, because you don't
want to have all these
HTTP fetchers.
So it's a very similar
technique, except this is done
with WebGL and textures.
OK, so on that note, I will let
Alexis take over and show
you a little bit more about
this experience.
Now, this was WebGL.
A little bit later on in the
experience, he'll show you CSS
custom filters in action
on some of the content.
So over to you.
ALEXIS DEVERIA: OK,
thanks, Alex.
So I scroll down through the
article, and once again, we
see another image.
We changed the opacity filter
once we scrolled into view.
Here, once again, we see
another CSS shape.
As you can see, this time the
text follows the contour of
the base of these trees here.
Again, looks great as
part of the image.
Very hard to do without
this technology.
Scrolling down to the
end of the article,
I get to this map.
And there's a couple of things
I want to show you here.
First of all, we see yet
another CSS shape.
This time, we follow the shape
of the state of California.
And as you can imagine, if you
try to do this today, you
would have to either do this
using an image, or by
hand-coding every single
line here.
And you can imagine the
problems with that.
I mean, anytime you need to make
a change, you'd have to
actually go in and change
the text and
redo the entire graphic.
You wouldn't get the indexing
or searching that you get by
all this just being text, so
that just makes it a very
useful technology to have for
any kind of typographical
effect like this.
We also have here
an infographic.
Click here.
This is a SVG graphic that shows
you the elevation range
of the sequoias.
We use more exclusions
here for this text.
And now, to show you our CSS
filter in action here, once I
click on this button, you can
see the page peels away to
reveal this other content.
And let me actually go back
and show that again.
So you can see this is all just
HTML and CSS content, and
we use a custom shader or a
custom filter or a CSS shader
to do that.
So this brings another
infographic.
Here we can see the tree.
I can click on these different
parts of it to reveal the
different sections.
We did this using 2D Canvas.
And so that about wraps it up
for the desktop browser
experience.
And I'd like to mention
that actually,
anybody can see this.
We have it on GitHub.
We'll share the link of
this with you later.
But when you do--
let's go back to the top here.
At the bottom here, there's
a bar that says
show editor's marks.
If you click on that, that shows
this annotated view that
actually highlights the
different technologies that
I've just been through, so you
can see for yourself how we
designed this page.
Great.
Back to you, Alex.
ALEX DANILO: Thanks, Alexis.
All righty.
Now of course, we told you
we're going to talk about
mobile, because this stuff was
shown last week at [? Max, ?]
which is great.
But today, we're actually going
to show you this running
on a mobile device, and it blows
your mind to see how far
this has come, and how fast it
is, and how beautiful the
experience is.
But of course, when you're
building stuff for mobile,
performance really
matters, right?
So nothing comes for free.
So the most important thing is
to test on many, many devices,
especially your target device.
Really think about how much
memory you're using, both for
RAM and texture memory,
if you're using
WebGL or custom filters.
There are a couple of
sessions coming up.
I highly recommend
you see them.
There's a session directly after
this one in this room,
which is web page design
with the GPU in mind.
I highly recommend you listen to
that one and a few others.
So while these guys were
building the mobile
experience, it came to how would
you actually deploy this
on mobile today?
And of course you can just take
Chrome on your mobile
device and point it at that
website that we've just shown
you, and it works great.
The thing is that for a next
generation reading experience,
people are used to the
whole app model.
Maybe we download an app, it
gives me my little icon that I
can tap on, and it's a
self-contained thing.
I don't have to type a URL
or anything like that.
So it gives you a few options.
So there are options, whether
you want to go completely
native, or whether you want
to have just a website, or
whether you go to some
kind of packaged web
container like PhoneGap.
And so this experience we're
about to show you was built
using PhoneGap.
It's an experimental build that
enables a whole lot of
features that currently aren't
in browsers, but it does show
you the capability, and
it's pretty cool.
So why don't we take a little
bit of a look at the National
Geographic experience
on the Nexus 10?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: OK,
thanks, Alex.
So, just for those of you
unfamiliar with PhoneGap,
PhoneGap is a framework that
lets you create applications
using web technologies on
different platforms.
It also gives you access to the
APIs that you would not
normally have access
to in the browser.
So we used that to
create this.
And so I'm going to
launch this app.
As you can see when it
starts, we start with
the same WebGL animation.
As you can see, it's very
smooth, very slick, looks
beautiful on the device.
And once that completes, that
brings us to this table of
contents view.
So here, I can select
our article.
And so for the application
experience, we wanted to do
something other than just have
some vertically scrolling page
as users expect on the web.
So in this case, we've got a
paginated reading experience
where I can scroll
horizontally through the content.
So here we see the same content
that we saw in the
browser, so we have the same
exclusion here around the
letter O. We also have some
interactive elements.
Here, I can use multi-touch
to take this
picture and enlarge it.
And as you can see here, it
makes a lot of sense to also
use regions to define each
container for the
text to flow through.
So that gave us a lot of freedom
exactly to define how
we wanted the content to appear
without having to
modify the text that was
actually in the paragraphs
that make up the content.
So see here, again, we have text
balancing regions, and
this brings us to our first use
of a CSS shader on mobile.
So what you can see here, once
I put two fingers on this
image, we flip to show the
other part of the image.
I can move my fingers around, I
can open and close, and if I
open them up, that shows this
image in full screen.
As you can see, when I scroll,
you can also see how the
lighting changes.
So that's all done
using the GPU.
It's a beautifully smooth, high
frame rate experience.
You move through the content,
and we see another beautiful
image-- again, the CSS shapes
that we were seeing before on
the web experience.
And once again, here's
another image.
If I tap on that, it flips out
to show the full screen.
And this one, too.
I can use the multi-touch
to open and close.
And so that creates a great
experience for the users that
you'd normally only see on
native applications, and we're
very happy to be able to
bring this to the web.
Here we see another map that
we also saw on the desktop.
This one has the same page curl
that you saw, except this
one does something a little bit
different where if I move
my finger, you can actually
see how the page curls
depending on the position
of my finger.
As you can see, it runs great.
I let go, and this reveals
a Google Map.
Because since we're using web
technologies, it means that we
can use APIs like the
Google Map API.
And now I can actually zoom in
and see the location of the
national park where
the sequoias grow.
And after that, I get
to our last page.
We see the same infographic
before.
I can use multi-touch to
make this one bigger.
And we see that in fullscreen.
So that about summarizes
the mobile experience.
There's one more thing I'd like
to show here, which you
might find interesting.
And just to prove that these are
indeed web technologies,
what we can do here is we're
going to plug the tablet into
this computer and run an ADB
command, which lets us
communicate with the
Android device.
So if I switch back
to desktop--
ALEX DANILO: OK, so we're just
going here to another tab,
which we're going to point
at a local host, with--
and hopefully, we'll
see the page.
So what we actually see here is
a reference to the content
that's actually running
on the tablet.
So this lets us pull up all the
Chrome Developer Tools and
actually debug the experience.
So this is the huge advantage
of taking this approach for
mobile applications.
Because it's built on web
technology, you have all the
tools at your fingertips.
You can debug the entire
experience, and you've seen
the performance, so you get
a really native style
performance built with web
technology, and you can debug
it properly.
Like, no more [INAUDIBLE]
adb logcat.
You can actually use
proper tools.
So why don't I just flip
back and forth?
Alexis will highlight a few
elements in this, and we'll
just prove to you this
is a real thing.
ALEXIS DEVERIA: So this is
me turning on and off the
shape-inside property
here, for example.
ALEX DANILO: So here you go.
He'll play with the shape-inside
property, and
we'll watch it change
live on the device.
Go back?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: So that
was that right there.
ALEX DANILO: So this is a huge
advantage of using web
technologies for this
kind of application.
It's a really, really
nice way to do it.
Now, let's just--
you have to wait for that one.
OK, so what's next?
The next level of CSS filters?
I've shown you the basic filters
that are already
there, the custom filters which
are in development at
the moment.
Another thing that is already
in the browsers today but is
improving rapidly
are SVG filters.
And the reason they're really
improving rapidly is because
they've been thrown
at the GPU.
So right now, in the channels
of Chrome, there's hardware
accelerated SVG filters
coming.
They're actually implemented
now.
They're just not finished
completely yet.
However, what this means is
you can take all those
building blocks I showed you
at the beginning of the
presentation, and you can chain
them together any way
you like, and it all runs on
the GPU, which is just
sensational.
So if you can imagine this
picture at the bottom-- this
beautiful, clear picture-- this
is in actual fact a movie
with a displacement
filter on it.
And how do you do that?
You do it with something
like this.
So the markup is very simple.
So here's an element selector
for video, and it's applying
the filter with a
URL reference.
And you can see it
references an ID.
So that's basically how you
apply it to your content.
And then in the SVG, which I
expect people will share
filters between each other,
there are two
filters shown here.
One is a convolution filter--
so you can basically use an
arbitrary convolution matrix
and apply it to your content.
The second filter applies
a blur followed by a
convolution.
And this is all runs in the
browser, hardware accelerated,
and I will prove it to you
by showing you this.
Here is a nice little movie
with no filter on it.
But of course, if we were to
put a blur on it, it would
look something like this.
So there you have it.
Full speed video with
blur, hardware
accelerated, in the GPU.
But of course, SVG has a whole
lot of primitives, so here is
a point light filter.
And what's nice about this
is there's a little event
listener on mouse move here,
which actually moves the
position of the light.
So this is all happening in your
favorite browser, or my
favorite browser, anyway.
So there's also a spotlight.
There are a few different
lighting primitives in SVG
which are really quite
nice to do all
sorts of amazing effects.
We have a morphology
filter, which--
I don't know if it's applicable
to video, but
anyway, it works.
You can flip the colors around,
you can play with the
color channels, and do all
sorts of crazy things.
Now, here's the convolution
filter that I showed in the
previous slide.
So this is actually a
convolution matrix that is
doing edge detection.
And so it gives you this
kind of lineart thing.
And if we actually use the
second filter on the previous
slide, there's the blur followed
by the convolution.
It gives you this kind
of result-- so a
blurry lineart thing.
All right, so we can do offset,
so you can basically
offset your graphics.
So you don't even need to use
relative positioning.
You could actually do it
with a filter, if you
really felt like it.
Then, of course, we can play
with a retro feel.
We can go to black and white.
Actually, that's kind
of cool, isn't it?
But you can do anything with
the color channels.
That's the beauty of it.
You can do all sorts of stuff.
So we could do, like, a noir
effect, which is kind of a
funky old style thing,
or do a bit of blue.
So you can imagine that
you're in the ocean.
And of course, we'll finish up
with the displacement filter.
So the displacement filter is
a really useful one, and I
can't wait for you guys to get
out there and start playing
with this one and build all
sorts of crazy sites.
So if you can imagine, when
you're on your desktop, and
you've got Windows up, you
iconize it, and you see the
rectangular thing
go woosh, like a
genie back into a bottle.
Well, the displacement filter
lets you do things like that.
So in effect, it's a warp, but
what it does is it takes an
input image and uses one of
the R or G or B color
channels, and uses the value
in the pixel as an offset
that's applied to the content.
And so this is an example.
Actually, we should probably
go further
forward in the video.
Why don't I go somewhere--
there.
That's better.
So you can actually see the
content is really crazily
warped around with this
input image with the
displacement filter.
OK, so what I really want
everybody in this room to do
is go to their favorite site
and put CSS filters on it,
because you can do some
incredible stuff, and we're
hardware accelerating the
whole lot of it now.
And so it means that your site
just gives you another piece
of creative sugar to put on
top of your sites and make
them beautiful.
Now, this National Geographic
experience, which we showed
you today-- the whole thing
is open source.
So if you go to the URL at the
top, you can actually get a
hold of all the content, so you
can see how it was built,
see everything, use
the content.
The second link there is a link
to the actual experience
itself, so you can view it.
I'd encourage everyone to start
playing with the stuff,
looking at it, seeing
what they can do.
Your browser's there.
You can debug it on mobile
if you really want to.
And with that, I think we're
pretty much done.
What do you think, Alexis?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: That's right.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX DANILO: Thank you.
OK, we've got plenty of
time for questions.
So, do we have any--
ALEXIS DEVERIA: One
other point.
ALEX DANILO: Oh, yes.
One other thing.
We'll be up at the Chrome
Sandbox right after this talk,
so if anybody has further
questions they don't want to
ask now, come and visit us.
And also, on level three at
the Adobe Sandbox, they're
actually showing this
on the Nexus 10.
So you can get your own fingers
on it, play with the
mobile experience, and
see for yourselves.
So anyway, questions.
AUDIENCE: I got here late, so
I'm not sure if you already
addressed it, but I
was wondering--
I realized it's mostly taking
place on the GPU, but how is
battery consumption with
all that animation?
ALEX DANILO: Well, in fact,
battery consumption is reduced
when you throw it on the GPU.
So typically, the GPU uses a lot
less battery power to any
of these kind of effects.
So it's pretty cheap,
actually.
AUDIENCE: But do you know what
the percent reduction is?
Because I know that playing
video on a phone would be a
lot of battery consumption.
ALEX DANILO: Playing it on the
phone, I think you'll probably
find a lot of battery
consumption is actually the
radio being on and pulling the
content across, more than the
GPU itself.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
ALEX DANILO: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there any way to
determine how much texture
memory the device that you're
on has for the WebGL stuff?
Because I saw the image for
the tree was pretty large.
Do you ever hit a maximum where
it just stops working,
or it crashes?
ALEX DANILO: That's why I
said test, test, test.
We are actually looking at ways
to measure GPU memory.
This has been asked quite a
number of times from a lot of
mobile developers, and we don't
have a good answer for
that just yet.
But come to the next session,
and I'm sure they'll tell you
all sorts of cool tricks.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: I have been playing
with CSS filters, and I've
been surprised a few times
when some things are
accelerated, and other
things aren't.
Is there a rule of thumb that I
can follow that will help me
decide whether or not this is
going to be GPU accelerated?
ALEX DANILO: I don't know
that there's any
clear rule of thumb.
We accelerate all of them in
Chrome now, and I know that
Mozilla have just rearchitected
the whole back
end of their rendering pipeline,
and they'll be
accelerating all
those as well.
In general, if you're scared,
just don't use blur, because
blur is the only one
that really hurts
you in software rendering.
The rest of the filters
are pretty good.
Or if you really want to use
blur, because it's useful,
make sure you keep the blur
small, because it's square.
Like, it's an order n-squared.
So if you do a 2 pixel blur or
a 4 pixel blur, the 4 pixel
blur is 4 times the
2 pixel blur in
terms of cost of rendering.
AUDIENCE: Got it, thanks.
ALEX DANILO: John?
AUDIENCE: So what are the
requirements on mobile, in
terms of WebKit?
And can you talk a bit about
what you've actually
contributed to PhoneGap
to make it all work?
ALEX DANILO: In which respect?
AUDIENCE: Actually, I"ll
ask a simpler question.
What version of Android
is the minimum to run
something like this on?
ALEX DANILO: Well,
PhoneGap person--
Alexis, can you tell
us, what's the
minimum Android for PhoneGap?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: I think the
basic PhoneGap should just run
on, I believe, most Android
versions, including 2.x.
But what we did here today that
we actually used this
custom version of PhoneGap to
make this possible, so we
could have the hardware
acceleration working as
swiftly as possible.
AUDIENCE: So does that need a
custom version of WebKit?
Or are you using [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: It's both a
custom version of PhoneGap and
a custom version
of WebKit, yes.
AUDIENCE: Can we get
that version?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: Not yet.
ALEX DANILO: The question was,
can you get that version?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: So it's just a
very prototyped stage, so we
hope eventually the code that
Adobe's been working on-- we
hope that that might get into
Blink or WebKit eventually,
but don't quite know
for sure, no.
AUDIENCE: Was there any
timeline [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: No.
No time known yet.
ALEX DANILO: Sir?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
subpixel rendering and then
applying filters, which
seems weird to me.
Because once you've subpixeled
it, if you filter it, it no
longer hits the subpixels.
ALEX DANILO: Well, what I was
saying was that you could do
the subpixel rendering, but
then you can do a vertex
shader, which will manipulate
the content.
So there's something like the
page flip, for example--
the filter is only moving
the content around.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
So not when it's static.
ALEX DANILO: Yeah.
So you still get the nice,
clean typography, so the
filter's not actually messing
with how it looks.
AUDIENCE: But you presumably
get sparkle when
you do that, then?
Because the subpixel?
ALEX DANILO: Oh, well, the
subpixel rendering is there,
right, so that as the page is
flipping, you don't suddenly
see a flip from nice typography
to blocky gray
anti-alias as the page
flips, right?
So it stays nice.
Do you understand?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yep.
Makes sense.
Cool.
ALEX DANILO: All right.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I'm just wondering if you can
say anything about the
designer experience of doing
a site like the National
Geographic one.
Did you have to design custom
tools, or was it done in a
text editor for some of these
special effects, or how did
you set that up?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: So are
you just talking
about the custom filters?
AUDIENCE: Well, perhaps you
guys designed the pages
yourselves, but I'm wondering
if maybe a regular graphic
designer came in as well,
and [INAUDIBLE]
visual layout tool.
ALEXIS DEVERIA: No, it was
all designed by Adobe.
National Geographic gave us
content, and gave us a little
bit of idea of what kind of
layout they had in mind.
But the whole design process and
implementation was done by
us Adobe guys.
And so the CSS filter
that we used--
the one on the web
is actually--
if you go to CSS Filter Lab, if
you just Google CSS Filter
Lab, you can see a whole bunch
of filters that we actually
developed at Adobe, and so the
page curl one is one of those,
and that's what we
included there.
So does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: I guess so.
I guess I'm just trying to think
about it in terms of, to
address somebody who's not a
programmer, but who might want
to say, oh, I really would like
to have this page pinch
open right here, but I don't
know how to do that.
ALEXIS DEVERIA: Well, because
this is still in very early
stages, there's not a lot
of tooling for it yet.
The spec is still
being developed.
But I can promise you that Adobe
specifically will make
sure that this will become
easier for developers.
ALEX DANILO: I think you need
to follow the Adobe Web
Platform blog, because they're
developing a ton of tools.
They've got a whole suite of
tools, and more and more are
being developed.
So we're showing you leading
edge stuff that's still active
in browser development and
standards development.
And so once they're locked down,
they'll be producing
tools for this stuff for sure.
AUDIENCE: Oh, cool.
Thank you very much.
ALEX DANILO: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So my question
pertains to availability and
compatibility.
So I just gave the website that
you were demoing a try on
Chrome 28 on my Pixel, and it
said I needed to turn on
Experimental WebKit features.
And I did, and it runs great,
and that's awesome.
But do you happen to know the
timeline on when that will be
in the general Chrome release?
ALEX DANILO: Very
good question.
I think that this is one of
those open ended questions,
because some of the features,
like the simple filters and
the SVG filters, all
work currently.
They're all standardized.
The custom filters and some of
that stuff, and the regions
and exclusions are currently
going through the
standardization process
in W3C.
And so that's a kind of
open ended thing.
I can't give you an answer
of exactly when.
Hopefully soon.
But for now, this is basically
an example of where the
technology is being developed
in parallel to
standardization, so that when
we go to the W3C and other
browser vendors, you can
go, look, here's an
implementation.
It works, it's cool.
And then everybody can argue
out the fine detail of how
that will finish up.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you very much.
ALEX DANILO: Yep.
Welcome.
John, another question.
AUDIENCE: My second question.
I'm actually excited
about this.
One of the issues I've had with
mobile web is having to
deal with different
versions of WebKit
on different platforms.
So are your contributions to
Cordova, does that mean I can
pick a version of WebKit
and deploy that?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: No, for Cordova,
you're stuck with the
WebKit that is on the device.
I believe there's talk of
possibly changing that in the
future, but that's the
way it is now.
AUDIENCE: So my first question,
then-- doesn't that
mean there'll be minimum
requirements for the mobile OS
for me to use these features?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: Yes,
that's correct.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
I'm less excited.
ALEX DANILO: Get excited, John.
It's good.
OK, yes sir.
AUDIENCE: On mobile,
I understand
that test, test, test.
But I wonder if amongst the
different mobile graphics
accelerators, you've noticed
that certain of these
operations perhaps tend to work
well, and others maybe
not so much?
ALEX DANILO: Yes,
very good point.
One of the things about the
mobile GPU to keep in mind--
I mean, the next session will
dive deep into this stuff.
But the technique of rendering
on a mobile GPU is completely
different to a desktop.
So on a desktop GPU, you
basically have a ton of
parallel execution units, and so
your rendering goes blot in
a huge wide thing, and happens
instantaneously.
And it's brute force.
Whereas on a mobile device,
because you want to keep the
silicon small, they use this
kind of deferred rendering
technique where they buffer up
all the things that are going
to be drawn, and kind of build
display lists and a stack of
stuff, and try to then eliminate
the things they
don't need to draw,
and then draw it.
So because of that, you actually
end up using a whole
lot of memory in the process.
But one little tip that's really
useful when doing this
stuff for mobile is to try and
keep the pieces of your
content small.
So, for example, if you're doing
a long list, like an
infinite list style of thing,
and you have a long, thin
strip like this, if you go
put a translate-z hack or
something like that to force
it into the GPU layer, the
problem with doing that is that
textures have to be square.
So if you've got a long, thin
strip like this, maybe it
consumes a megabyte, but
your square texture
could be 100 megabytes.
And so you've blown out
all your GPU memory.
And I've seen really janky sites
where people have done
this, and then simply by
changing the CSS selector to
put that transform on the
little pieces of content
within the strip, you would
think that would cost more
time, because of all the
extra CSS [INAUDIBLE]
recalculation.
But in actual fact, what happens
is the tiles end up
these little tiny tiles that
then go over to the GPU, and
the thing flies.
So as a general rule of thumb,
try and keep content that's
accelerated small.
And especially with the WebGL
tree, you saw it was all
chopped into little squares
or little rectangles.
That was a similar
kind of idea.
AUDIENCE: So following up on
that, with the WebGL 3, you
mentioned how difficult it is to
get the texture to the GPU,
and that you put a little
spinner in there to make it a
better user experience.
Would you have this problem
with GPU accelerated CSS
filters, or even
custom filters?
And what can you do about it?
Is there a lag due to the
texture going through the GPU
when you use those pre-built
filters?
ALEX DANILO: You would have that
problem with the custom
filters, because it's
the same issue.
You have to get the texture
of the rendered content.
So effectively, your browser is
laying out, rendering, and
then it's creating a bitmap,
which it then passes across to
the GPU for it to
use a texture.
So you will have that problem
for those filters.
For the SVG filters, not
so much, because--
well, I suppose you would.
I guess it depends
on your content.
But if you're playing video,
for example, where I showed
the SVG accelerated filters
on the video, the video is
already on the GPU.
So that bitmap of the video is
never seen on the CPU side.
It's decoded in hardware.
That's sitting in the GPU
memory, and then when the SVG
filter is applied, it's
all happening as a
texture in GPU memory.
So there's never a
read back to CPU.
So you don't get the same
flip-flop of textures happening.
AUDIENCE: And so if you have
the issue with CSS custom
filters, is there anything you
can do for displaying a
spinner, for instance?
ALEX DANILO: Probably
lots of things.
Well, similar to displaying
the spinner.
But I think that you probably
find that would just be an
initial load, because if the
custom filter is sitting
there, the browser already knows
it needs to put it in
the texture.
So the moment you see
it, it's ready to go
to do its flip effect.
It's just how quickly
that loads.
I think in the actual National
Geographic one, because the
custom shader was down the
bottom, the custom filter was
right at the bottom of the page,
that was just loading in
the background while you're
viewing the top.
So your standard techniques--
show something to the user as
the fancy content is loading
in the background.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
ALEX DANILO: OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you tracking fine
grain abilities of what
works on Can I Use for these?
Which filters are on
which platforms?
ALEXIS DEVERIA: Hopefully
filters is a feature
that's on Can I Use.
I think it's just basic filters
right now, but as that
gets more complicated, then
I'll definitely add more
subfeatures or whatever.
ALEX DANILO: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I don't know
whether this is just Moscone
Wi-Fi being Moscone Wi-Fi, but
the website that you guys were
using-- the GitHub
site to demo the
National Geographic thing--
stopped working.
I refreshed the page, and it
says it can't connect to that.
Do you know if that's a
connection problem, or is that
being moved somewhere?
ALEX DANILO: I think it's
a connection problem.
So this is actually the page.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ALEX DANILO: I'll try
and reload it.
Oh, then again, maybe
it's Moscone Wi-Fi.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
ALEX DANILO: This is actually
a wired connection, so yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEX DANILO: Looks like the
network is down, folks.
Sorry about that.
OK, in that case, no
more questions?
And anyone quick, one
last question?
No one brave?
All right, thanks, everyone,
for coming to this session.
[APPLAUSE]